all right let's get into the mailbag it
is Friday time to look at what some of
you uh wrote to me over the last week
you can email info davidpackman.com
leave a YouTube comment leave leave
anything quite frankly we might use it
first one we sometimes start with
something negative I know the first one
today is from Jordan who is doing the
right thing he's using the wrong your in
hate mail which is almost required at
this point you're a bozo y-o-u-r Jordan
writes to me do you really think you
have everything figured out Joe Biden
has been on hibernation since 2020 and
this country is a power keg not a powder
keg it's a power keg just once I'd want
to see you honest with your Audience by
putting on clown makeup and a skirt if
you love Biden so much you should go to
sleep every day well you know Jordan I
do go to sleep every day I think
sleeping is really important and it is
stunning to me how someone like this can
hold any job any job
some of these folks could be your kids
teachers they might be your accountant
now maybe Jordan doesn't have a job I
don't know but
um
let's move on
I was uh surprised but I guess not
really you know we launched the Spanish
YouTube channel last week quite
literally within minutes of the Spanish
YouTube channel launching I got my first
hate Spanish email where Alexander wrote
to me
which means
son of a communist
trash blood I have trashy blood folks uh
don't you say anything about my blood
until you see my CBC results and you'll
be stunned
um no listen in all seriousness
the Spanish content is triggering people
left and right and it's wild and I told
you there's a lot of right-wing
conspiracy theories targeted at the
Spanish-speaking community and that's
why we've taken on this Spanish language
dubbing project over a thousand of you
have already subscribed if you've got
friends family parents cousins whoever
who wants to be getting content like
what we create but they would rather get
it in Spanish than in English tell them
about
davidpackman.com
Spanish
Spanish Scott wrote in about my mustache
and says David sir so much commentary
from viewers who are activated and
triggered by any changes to the show set
background guest hosts your attire Etc
please Count Me In amongst those who are
eagerly tuning in to watch the progress
of the mustache looking better every day
my friend that's Scott in New York City
well thank you you know I was going to
start it only as a goof but I'm sort of
enjoying the mustache when people see me
who haven't seen me for you know a few
weeks or a couple of months I noticed
that they do a double take but they
don't want to bring it up and I'll
immediately say it's the mustache right
and they can't help but say yes it is
the mustache this is a satirical
mustache to be completely clear but it
is generating interest and Intrigue and
that is really more than I can ask for
so I'm going to keep it going uh the
Shaving has much improved it's all it's
it's just it's all going really really
well is what I would say Scott so we're
going to keep it going for the time
being okay a couple emails about my
interview with Patrick Bet David when I
was down in Florida a couple weeks ago
Craig Rhoden about the pbd approach to
debating Craig says you talking about
him was the first I'd heard of him and
he just turned me off he would ask you a
question that I'm sure you would have a
straightforward answer to but then you
would immediately present an analogy
that he feels would trick you into
answering how he would like then when
you ask him straightforward questions he
wouldn't answer instead he would ask
where are you going with this thinking
you are trying to trick him into saying
the wrong thing and he doesn't want to
get beat at his own game also his come
on you're a smart person is very
condescending I'm curious your thoughts
thanks that's Craig from Maui yeah Craig
you're right about everything you're
saying I thought it was super
interesting perfectly nice guy you know
and we chatted very briefly before and
after the show and
um all of it and perfectly nice guy but
um I did think that it wasn't
necessarily bad faith it did seem in a
way that he was just so careful not to
fall into any kind of a trap like when I
said to him
when you think about the tax rate you're
willing to pay like are you willing to
pay more if you get more for your taxes
like if it included college and Health
Care would you be willing to pay more
than if it didn't it really wasn't a
trick question it was trying to open a
conversation about what we value and he
was saying something like well I don't
think we're spending it the right way
and I'm like that's not the question I'm
asking sir
um Craig's assessment is pretty pretty
spot on
uh and and maybe I will have another
opportunity to try again Renee also
wrote in about the interview with
Patrick Bet David and said hi David I'm
listening to your chat with Patrick Bett
David I've never heard of this guy but
his arguments remind me so much of
trying to have a conversation with my
stepdad who's good-hearted but so
exasperating I'm not sure if I can make
it through this whole thing because when
you try to pinpoint one issue he throws
10 other random examples and says well
what about this what about that like
lending a bike to someone is the same as
centralizing how we fund health care
it's so hard to get anywhere with people
who have this world view but thank you
for trying yeah this was a very common
um sort of email I got feedback wise I
think the most interesting outcome of
the Patrick Bet David interview is that
usually the home team has a huge bias to
the host so for example I would expect
that when I upload my interviews with
pbd
um the comments would be mostly positive
about me and they were and I would
expect that on his channel the video we
did would be mostly positive about him
interestingly tons of his viewers on his
channel said in the comments you were
unnecessarily hostile this didn't go
well for you Pat etc etc the fact that
that was even
a noticeable portion of the feedback
from his audience is very interesting I
don't know what it means but it's
certainly very very interesting and I
would be interested in doing it again
nolita wrote In and says are you able to
post a link on the main webpage for the
Spanish broadcast I can't find it David
said it quickly I didn't catch it I'm
going to say the link again with total
peace and love
davidpackman.com
Spanish as of this moment we have
breached 1500 subscribers on the channel
and we got our first video with over a
thousand views on the Spanish Channel it
is extraordinarily exciting
extraordinarily exciting and we're going
to be putting in a bunch of different
resources into the project because I
think it is so important Ron wrote in
about the Ohio train derailment and Ron
said something I've been seeing
everywhere I've been seeing it on
Twitter I've been seeing it on Reddit
Ron says David can you provide coverage
of the Ohio train derailment I feel like
this is a major story that should be
getting more coverage but isn't getting
the attention it deserves I genuinely
don't understand why I am seeing this
comment everywhere there's a narrative
that's developed that nobody's talking
about the train derailment I see it
everywhere I I go to newyorktimes.com
it's about the train derailment I go to
Washington Post train derailment Fox
News train derailment because they want
to criticize Pete Buddha judge and Joe
Biden about it Reddit all over the train
derailment Twitter all over the trendy
Roman independent you know media we've
already done a number of clips about it
and so have many of our colleagues I am
not seeing
that there isn't coverage of this and I
don't know what people you know it's
happened in other cases where there's a
story that's like everywhere and you see
people saying this it's not getting any
coverage and yet everybody is talking
about it I don't really know where
that's coming from I'd be interested to
know more and if you have any sense of
why that narrative is being repeated let
me know because I am seeing coverage
about every aspect of this what caused
it the controlled burn Mike dewine the
chemicals is the water safe is the air
safe is the soil safe is this Buddha
judge's fault or not is this Joe Biden's
fault or not the Obama regulations that
Donald Trump rolled I'm seeing every
aspect of the story covered extensively
and it is an important story so we
should be seeing that but I'm just not
seeing the lack of coverage let me know
if you know where that's coming from we
have such a great bonus show for you to
you can sign up so quickly
at joinpakman.com if you want to pay the
normal prices that's great I believe
that they're eminently reasonable six
bucks a month 60 for the year if that
strikes you as high for your financial
situation no problem I have a coupon
code for you that code is 24 starts now
the number 2424 starts now no spaces
okay 2024 really does start right now
we're in the middle of it already sign
up you'll get the bonus show the
commercial free audio and video feeds of
the show invitations to our members only
town halls and access to the sound board
Obama yeah we have a soundboard in the
members section of the website
for our members check it out we will see
you on the bonus show momentarily